eric dupond moretti avocat bête
médiatique ce faire il apparaît à la
télé pour la première fois en 1987 peu
après ses débuts je vous rappelle que ma
cliente est incarcéré et qu'elle n'est
pas encore jugé michel goudard ne peut
pas être condamné il ne doit pas l'être
mais il prend vraiment la lumière en
2005 avec l' affaire d'outreau et
affiche un certain goût de la formule et
c'est pour nous un immense soulagement
envoyer la saint-yves c'est la fête des
avocats mais je pense est aujourd'hui la
saint-yves voilà grande gueule admirez
détester redouté en 35 ans de carrière
il a enchaîné les dossiers médiatisés
sas a de la gueule il appert garbiel ton
arrêt de dire celle affaire kerviel
c'est d'abord la sphère société générale
karabatic d'affaires des paris truqués
que les karabatic je savais pas un
battage médiatique c'est un abattage et
des clients controversés comme abd el
kader meira le frère du terroriste
toulousain
la télé lui a consacré plusieurs
portraits fasciné par l'homme derrière
l'avocat l'avocat est aussi chasseur du
genre carnassiers adeptes de la chasse
au faucon une gouaille et un charisme
qui intéresse le cinéma notamment claude
lelouch en 2017 pour chaque camp sa vie
dès qu'ils se lèvent dans le prétoire
on n'entend plus nous je volais on sent
que la tension des gens est captée et je
me dis cette attention il faut que ma
caméra en profite
eric dupond-moretti apparaît dans quatre
autres films et s'essaie désormais au
théâtre
[Musique]